tu vas rester un petit peu chez ton
oncle et ta tante tu seras en sécurité
ici vous allez où vous deux ta mère et
moi on a quelque chose à faire je veux
venir avec vous faut y
aller alors parlez-nous un peu de vous
monsieur
Parker franchement il y a pas grand
chose à
dire Peter habite avec sa tante et son
oncle je l'avais complètement oublié
c'était à ton
père qu'est-ce que tu fais là euh moi
rien évite de m'attirer des ennuis ne
touche à
[Musique]
rien
Peter qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive prêt à jouer les
dieux as-tu la moindre idée
de ce que tu es
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réellement on a tous des
[Musique]
secrets ce que l'on
cache et ce que l'on nous
cache